In this lesson we've learned just a teeny bit
more about ways we can trace through our maternal
or paternal lines. So in the case of mitochondrial
DNA we only inherit that from our mothers. So
you can trace your maternal line back through the
mitochondrial DNA. The mitochondria have been passed down from
generation to generation. From great-great-great grandmother to great-great to
great to grandmother to mother to you. Now the
same thing is true for the Y chromosome for males.
Every male is genetically XY and he had to have
gotten that Y chromosome from his father, who got it
from his father who got it from his father, who
got it from his father, and so this Y chromosome
has just been passed down. From generation to generation, through
all of the male line. One of the big distinctions
here, is that Mitochondrial DNA, everybody has. But the Y
chromosome, only males have. We're going to revisit these
concepts a little bit later, in lesson seven.
When we actually try to trace an individual's
lineage, on both his mother's and father's side.